bonjour et bienvenue à Bruxelles nous
sommes au cœur du Parlement européen
comme toujours cette semaine direction
les étoiles le 12 novembre 2014 un petit
robot filae s'est posé sur une comète
nous avons rencontré les scientifiques
qui ont porté cette mission dans
l'espace la mission Rosetta n'est pas
finie mais y a-t-il encore un budget
pour financer les grands programmes
spations en Europe nous en discuterons
avec deux invités mais d'abord
l'actualité la Banque centrale
européenne est un acteur incontournable
dans la zone euro mais est-elle sortie
de son rôle c'est la question que nous
poserons à notre invité Robert Rochefort
député européen vice-président de la
Commission du marché intérieur d'abord
explication en images
c'est la tour de contrôle de l'eurosone
installé à Francfort en Allemagne la
Banque centrale européenne a pour
mission de garantir la stabilité des
prix son statut lui interdit de prêter
directement aux États contrairement à la
Réserve fédérale américaine ou à la
Banque d'Angleterre
mais les temps changent la crise de la
dette qui frappe le continent en 2008
conduit la BCE à intervenir de plus en
plus pour voler au secours des états
endettés sans violer les traités elle
utilise ce qu'elle appelle des
instruments non conventionnels une
palette de techniques qui lui permet
notamment de racheter massivement de la
dette publique sur les marchés des bons
du Trésor grec espagnol portugais elle
prête aussi des centaines de milliards
d'euros aux banques de la zone l'annonce
d'un ralentissement de l'activité en
Europe fait monter la pression sur la
BCE le spectre de la déflation la
conduit à intervenir à nouveau sur la
politique monétaire elle lance un
programme de rachat illimité de dette
italienne française ou allemande bute de
l'opération faire baisser les taux
d'intérêt pour inciter les investisseurs
à prendre plus de risques alors la BCE
est-elle désormais au service de la
croissance européenne
avec nous Robert Rochefort bonjour
bonjour Merci d'être sur le plateau
d'Europe Hebdo vous êtes débuté membre
du groupe ADLE le modem en France enfin
vous avez été élu sous les couleurs de
modem vous êtes membre de la commission
du marché intérieur et des consommateurs
vous êtes économiste vous allez nous
expliquer un peu la portée de toutes ces
interventions de la Banque centrale
européenne est-ce que cette BCE serait
mise au service de la croissance
européenne
il faut d'abord dire merci à Monsieur
Draghi monsieur Draghi est depuis
quelques temps le seul leader européen
qui est à la hauteur de la situation
mais il faut dire aussi qu'il est le
seul à la tête d'une institution
fédérale donc il lui permet de faire des
choses donc Mario Draghi président de la
BCE dans Mario Draghi président de la
BCE ce qu'il fait est très bien il va
jusqu'au bout des limites possibles que
le traité lui permet mais soyons clairs
une politique monétaire est au favorise
une politique de croissance mais ne peut
pas à elle toute seule relancer la
croissance économique la responsabilité
des États oui parce que il y a deux
sujets pour que la croissance reparte en
Europe premièrement il faut un plan
d'investissement massif alors c'est ce
qu'on appelle ici le plan Juncker sur
des grands investissements qui
concernent l'Union européenne massif que
ça d'ailleurs parce que oui il est quand
même il est quand même significatif il
pourrait être plus élevé vous savez que
les États avaient la possibilité de
l'abonder en mettant de l'argent
supplémentaire mais aucun des états n'a
voulu le faire ce qui au passage me
permet de vous dire que le troisième
facteur et qui par contre la manque
c'est une politique économique cohérente
entre les différents états tant que nos
politiques économiques ne sont pas
harmonisées et bien tout ça est un peu
freiné donc la BCE fait beaucoup mais
c'est pas suffisant mais en tout cas
c'est c'est trop déjà pour un pays comme
l'Allemagne qui qui redoute que cela un
mauvais signal pour les pays l'exemple
que je vous indiquais voilà l'exemple
que je vous indiquais il y a des
divergences il y a les faucons c'est
l'Allemagne il y a les pays du Sud qu'on
se considère souvent comme des pays
laxistes mais en deux mots qu'est-ce que
fait la BCE la BCE pour la période tout
à fait récente vient de lancer ce qu'on
appelle le programme de quantitative
easing c'est-à-dire de rachat de dettes
pour une somme très très importante de
toutes les dettes toutes les dates
françaises absolument allemand sauf grec
d'ailleurs la grec qui ne pourra pas la
racheter parce que la BCE ne peut pas
avoir à un moment donné plus d'un tiers
de la dette publique d'un état dans ses
livres or là la Grèce est déjà tellement
aidé
a été tellement aidé que pour l'instant
c'est pas vers la Grèce
alors sauf que si la Grèce rembourse ces
échéances à court terme elle pourra de
nouveau prétendre puisque d'une certaine
façon leur remboursé à la BCE elle
pourra réemprunter alors il y a quelque
chose qui peut paraître un peu étrange
mais c'est souvent comme ça que ça
marche juste un mot quand même
la BCE en faisant ce rachat massif non
seulement incite à ce que l'argent reste
pas cher donc normalement ça permet à
l'économie de repartir quand il y a des
projets mais quand faut-il qu'il y a des
projets mais aussi elle est dans son
rôle puisque vous savez contrairement
aux reportage qui a été indiqué
l'objectif de la BCE c'est pas de ne pas
avoir d'inflation du tout c'est d'avoir
une inflation de 2% en cas de
aujourd'hui ce qui nous menace c'est la
déflation en Europe la déflation
c'est-à-dire une inflation négative et
ça c'est le pire des cauchemars alors
elle rachètera massivement ces dettes
publiques mais avec l'espoir que les
acteurs économiques les banques les les
entreprises et les consommateurs
puissent emprunter ou investir mais
encore faut-il que les banques jouent le
jeu encore faut-il surtout qu'il y a la
dette publique a racheté c'est ça qui
est un peu le paradoxe c'est que les
banques puisque vous en parlez les
banques aujourd'hui ont de la dette
publique des différents États mais les
banques ont besoin de placer dans des
dans ce qu'on appelle des emprunts qui
sont sûrs or les dettes d'État
aujourd'hui sont sûrs et les banques
finalement reçoivent aujourd'hui une
rémunération qui est quand même
significative pour ces dettes d'État
donc l'idée de la BCE et de racheter
cette dette des États mais quand c'est
dettes est déjà placé auprès des banques
il n'est pas sûr que les banques
effectivement donnent cette dette en
réalité ce que fait aussi la BCE c'est
très important c'est qu'elle donne un
signal psychologique et politique de
confiance elle dit elle dit on est là et
on soutiendra les choses mais vous avez
raison les banques ne vont peut-être pas
du coup récupérer de l'argent auprès de
la BCE pour placer dans l'économie mais
ce n'est pas vraiment complètement de la
faute des banques c'est de la faute de
ces politiques économiques qui ne sont
pas assez intégrés et surtout de ce plan
d'investissement dont j'ai parlé tout à
l'heure qui est un plan dans lequel nous
avons beaucoup d'espoir mais
reconnaissons le qui n'est pas encore
aujourd'hui très concret et très
opérationnel alors un petit mot très
vite de commentaires sur ce nouveau
délai accordé à la France par Bruxelles
qui lui donne donc deux ans plus pour
espérer rentrer dans les clous du pacte
de stabilité écoutez le commentaire de
Pierre Moscovici le commissaire aux
Affaires économiques
les réformes entreprises depuis deux ans
vont dans la bonne direction mais dans
le contexte actuel elles n'ont pas
encore suffit à corriger cette situation
sachant que l'objectif de 3 % n'est pas
atteignable en 2015 il fallait prendre
une nouvelle recommandation ce sera fait
dans les jours qui viennent avec une
trajectoire de retour vers 3% à
l'horizon 2017 soit un délai de deux ans
supplémentaires qui va exiger des
efforts importants de la part de la
France c'est très clair et la commission
sur ce point est tout à fait exigeante
alors deux ans de plus à la France qui
nous amène à 2017 aller électoral est-ce
que vous pensez qu'il y aura des qui
pourrait y avoir des sanctions si elles
ne respectent pas je suis triste pour
mon pays la France parce que vous voyez
bien que ce que nous demande Bruxelles
en l'occurrence c'est pas quelque chose
qui est fait pour faire plaisir à
Bruxelles c'est quelque chose qui est
important pour notre pays plus nous
retardons et là c'est la troisième fois
qu'on retarde plus c'est nous-mêmes que
nous pénalisons vous voyez bien parce
que là il va falloir faire quoi cette
année 4 milliards d'économies
budgétaires supplémentaires parce qu'on
les a pas fait dans les années
précédentes alors il y a la ça va
contraindre la croissance alors il y a
la loi Macron qui est actuellement
toujours en examen au Parlement européen
que le gouvernement a du mal à faire
passer d'ailleurs est-ce que ça ne
suffit pas pour Bruxelles vous vous
savez ce que c'est qu'un escargot vous
savez l'escargot c'est ce petit animal
il a une coquille comme ça c'est à dire
si on prend l'escargot par l'extérieur
on a l'impression qu'on tourne autour du
pot qu'on ne s'y rapproche que lentement
en tournant etc la loi Macron c'est
comme les réformes insuffisantes que
nous empêche qu'à présent c'est-à-dire
on va vers l'objectif central donc on y
va extrêmement lentement on ne s'attaque
pas à la chose la plus importante pour
conclure cette émission qu'elle est pour
vous la réforme prioritaire amenée en
France pour en entrée dans les il y en a
l'essentiel porte sur le marché du
travail assouplissement contrat contrat
de travail unique en contrepartie mettre
l'argent de la formation professionnel
au service des chômeurs c'est s'il
pourrait être quelque chose de
gagnant-gagnant et une réforme et une
simplification considérable du droit du
travail et des seuils du code du travail
et des seuils salariaux particuliers de
50 qui soit remis en cause parce que on
sait très bien que ça m'obstacle à la
croissance de l'activité économique en
France et c'est ça dont on a absolument
besoin et on en a pas fini d'en parler
merci beaucoup Robert Rochefort d'avoir
accès à vous alors loin du pacte de
stabilité je vous propose de rêver un
peu puisque l'Europe c'est aussi de
grands projets spatiaux le 12 novembre
2014 un petit robot s'est posé sur une
comète signant un exploit européen nous
avons rencontré les scientifiques qui
sont à l'origine de cette mission c'est
adamstad en Allemagne reportage signé
germandrieu et rallye de Mamoun
le 12 novembre 2014 à plus de 500
millions de kilomètres de la Terre la
sonde européenne Rosetta l'Argue filaïe
sur la comète tchourie l'atterrisseur
finit par se poser entre deux reliefs à
l'ombre du soleil et attend de recharger
ses batteries mais après 10 ans de
voyage interplanétaires l'émotion de
l'Agence spatiale européenne est immense
un jour historique pour les arbres
l'Agence spatiale européenne
voici le centre des opérations à
Darmstadt en Allemagne où toutes les
missions en cours sont suivies et
contrôlées
est loin d'être terminée
et plus de soleil pour recharger les
batteries et dans ce cas si cela se
produit nous aurons l'opportunité de
faire encore plus d'expérience avec
final
n'est qu'un des instruments de Rosetta
la sonde européenne vient de réussir
mi-février un survol de la comète
tchourie à seulement 6 km d'altitude
Rosetta continuera d'explorer de
photographier et de travailler en 2015
voire en 2016
de comprendre un peu de d'où vient le
l'origine de l'univers d'où vient le
voilà un peu d'où nous venons nous notre
histoire
la mission Rosetta c'est 1,3 milliards
d'euros au total sur 20 ans le rêve et
l'exploration spatiale ont un coût mais
le financement des programmes de
l'Agence spatiale européenne est très
clair si les 20 pays membres versent une
contribution proportionnelle à leur PIB
pour les programmes scientifiques
principaux il participe comme il le
souhaite dans les programmes facultatifs
comme l'exploration spatiale l'émission
comme celle de Rosetta sont à part elles
sont très longues et donc les résultats
n'arrivent qu'à la fin des opérations
mais ils sont spectaculaires je crois
qu'il faut mixer les différents types de
programmes il faut de nombreux résultats
scientifiques immédiats comme avec les
missions astronomiques mais aussi des
programmes qui demandent plus de temps
comme ceux de Rosetta avec un voyage de
plus de 10 ans
10 ans c'est aussi la durée du projet
Ariane 6 avec un premier vol en 2020 les
20 pays membres de l'ESA ont validé un
programme de 4 milliards d'euros c'est
aussi le prix d'indépendance de l'Europe
pour un accès à l'espace
et plus particulièrement l'accord sur le
futur d'Ariane est très important pour
l'Europe car il garantissent l'accès à
l'espace
mais le principal message c'est de dire
que si l'exploration spatiale n'existait
pas la vie de chaque européen ne serait
pas la même ce serait un retour en
arrière de 30 ou 40 ans
car les enjeux pour l'Europe sont aussi
économiques avec les marchés mondiaux de
la géolocalisation des
télécommunications ou encore de
l'environnement l'espace n'est plus un
club très restreint la concurrence est
aujourd'hui l'Inde la Corée ou encore la
Chine sans oublier la Russie et surtout
les États-Unis
retour sur Terre nous sommes à Bruxelles
au Parlement européen en compagnie de
deux invités de députés européens
Isabelle Thomas bonjour bonjour vous
êtes donc vice-présidente des
socialistes européens et vous êtes en
charge notamment des questions
budgétaires vous nous direz si il y a de
l'argent pour ces programmes et
Dominique criquet en face de vous êtes
membre de l'alliance des démocrates adde
à l'anse et démocrate et des libéraux
pour l'Europe une question à vous
peut-être on voit que ces programmes
comme la mission Rosetta demande des
années de recherche fruit d'une très
longue coopération de scientifiques
est-ce que ça veut dire que c'est le
signe que le vieux continent européen
fait encore rêvé tout simplement
de l'Europe l'espace parce que à la fois
c'est l'avenir à la fois c'est
formidable opportunités sur le plan
scientifique industriel commercial et
puis c'est aussi un symbole parce que si
l'Europe n'est pas unie les États
membres séparément n'ont pas accès à
l'espace d'être les coopérations comme
ça peuvent marcher qu'aucun pays
n'aurait pu réussir seul ce type de
mission les portes de l'Espace elle
passe par l'Europe
on va essayer d'y voir un peu plus clair
d'être réaliste en tout cas de devoir si
ce type de projet est financé alors
Rosetta les mais par exemple tous les
autres qui sont qui sont en cours
Galileo est-ce qu'il y a encore de
l'argent pour ce type de programme il y
a de l'argent dans le budget de l'Union
européenne ça et sur ces questions de
recherche il y a je rappelle que la
commission des budgets commission des
budgets donc environ plus de 13
milliards par an quand même mais surtout
il y a d'autant plus d'argent que
l'Union européenne est notamment la
proposition de la Commission européenne
ce n'est plus les restrictions
budgétaires c'est au contraire d'essayer
par une politique de relance de relancer
de revivifier l'économie de faire y
compris investir les l'argent privé qui
dorment malheureusement dans toute
l'Union européenne et qui sur le plan
économique aboutit à une Europe un peu
attein donc à la fois il y a de l'argent
et à la fois le paradoxe c'est que dans
ce projet de relance de la Commission
européenne il nous est proposé de couper
justement le budget de la recherche et
notamment horizon 20 20 que peut-être
tout le monde ne connaît pas mais qui
est une partie substantielle importante
la partie principale du budget de la
recherche européenne donc il y a un
paradoxe d'un côté on veut relancer
l'économie et de l'autre couper sur le
budget de la recherche
on le résout Dominique et ce qu'il faut
conserver de l'argent pour pour ces
secteurs stratégiques de l'espace
l'idée que
le fond européenne relance est
nécessaire simplement il faudra trouver
de meilleur garanties que celles qui
s'exerce sur des domaines qui sont
stratégiques en tout cas c'est cet
argent menacé d'après ce qu'explique que
votre votre collègue
l'argent existe encore que
un peu limité un peu juste pour les
ambitions que nous avons je pense qu'il
y aura
non seulement il faudra pas couper dans
les programmes mais il faudra au
contraire prévoir une possibilité de
rallonge dans les 5 ans qui viennent
très vraisemblablement le rallonge pour
pour garantir quel type de programme qui
serait prioritaire pour vous trois
Galileo ça parlons de Galiléo qui qu'on
attend toujours ça nous donne donc 22
satellites qui sont financés il en
faudrait au moins 4 ou 6 de plus ils
sont pas financés ceux-là encore pour 22
sont financés
et deuxièmement il faut se solidifier le
programme de lanceur parce que on
regarde s'apercevoir que probablement
pour Ariane 6 il manquait 3-400 millions
quand même alors justement je vous
propose d'écouter ce que dit l'un des
scientifiques que nous avons rencontré
lors de notre reportage il a une
question directe à vous poser écoutez
et des scènes space dans la mesure où
l'espace est important pour la
protection de la planète seriez-vous
prêt à prendre l'engagement de préserver
les activités spatiales en Europe
alors ce qui me concerne je l'ai dit
tout à l'heure je pense que
l'investissement en matière de recherche
c'est incontournable j'ajoute simplement
par rapport à la question qui est posée
que certes l'espace c'est très important
qu'il faut pas y toucher mais il y a
d'autres domaines de recherche qui sont
tout aussi importants je pense notamment
à ce qui représente quand même cette
dixième de la planète à savoir les
océans qui sont finalement aujourd'hui
moins connus peut-être que notre espace
proche et qui recouvre beaucoup moins
d'investissements alors que nous n'en
connaissons que la surface nous ne
connaissons quasiment rien mais les
océans ça c'est vrai mais est-ce que
tout de même vu le contexte actuel d'une
crise économique donc l'Europe n'est pas
encore sortie est-ce que ce type de
dépenses ne sont pas devenus un luxe
pour leur je vais vous donner un exemple
très concret
sur le maritime sur l'icône de ce qu'on
appelle l'économie bleue ou la
croissance bleue la Commission
européenne a fait une étude qui prévoit
que on peut on peut créer 1,6 millions
d'emplois supplémentaires en Europe
d'ici 2020 uniquement sur l'activité
économique maritime par exemple les
énergies marines renouvelables par
exemple
les cultures marines par exemple les
deux technologies marines qui qui ont
des conséquences dans la santé dans la
médecine etc donc non ce sont des
investissements pour créer de l'économie
et de l'emploi alors j'ai une question
pour vous Dominique Riquet on voit que
ces projets demandent de longues années
de recherche qu'il faut être patient
pour avoir les retombées pour vous quels
sont les retombées de ces programmes et
qu'est-ce que qu'est-ce que les citoyens
européens peuvent en attendre est-ce
qu'on peut espérer des choses très
concrètes pour pour la vie quotidienne
beaucoup de choses dans toutes les
télécommunications j'ai pas besoin
d'insister sur le fait à venir pour
l'Europe et bien sûr il faut qu'on ait
notre propre accès son propre système et
on est quand même des leaders mondiaux
dans les satellites de télécommunication
c'est une industrie c'est beaucoup
d'emplois donc conserver ce secteur là
il faut conserver ça il faut conserver
évidemment notre leadership deuxièmement
tout ce qui est système Galilée au
géolocalisation est devenu maintenant
indispensable pour toutes sortes
d'activités nous on est sensible au GPS
de la voiture mais ça sert dans
l'agriculture dans la navigation dans la
surveillance des océans d'ailleurs c'est
bien que je partage la vie sur
l'importance pour l'instant c'est les
Américains qui qui concernent le marché
quand est-ce que les Européens vont
le GPS américains que nous utilisons
actuellement faute de système européen
représente un retombé industriel
c'est-à-dire tout ce qui est système
d'exploitation quand vous achetez par
exemple votre GPS quand on le met dans
votre voiture mais il y a beaucoup
d'autres applications à beaucoup de
domaines 150 milliards de dollars par an
15 donc c'est de l'emploi donc c'est de
l'activité il y a encore beaucoup
d'autres secteurs des leaders dans la
morphologie sujet extrêmement important
pour les voyages des déplacements
d'agriculture le transport maritime donc
vraiment la porte de l'espace
indispensable aux technologies d'avenir
très clairement est-ce que cette
technologie d'avenir pourrait rentrer
dans le cadre du fameux plan Juncker
qu'on qui doit être développé ce fameux
plan d'investissement promis par
Jean-Claude Juncker qui repose
principalement rappelons-le sur les
investissements privés est-ce que ça se
pourrait intéresser effectivement des
choses qui vont rentrer dans le plan
yunker certainement mais attention
toutefois et c'est là où il faut être
prudent sur le budget enfin en tout cas
faire des coupes budgétaires sur la
recherche fondamentale parce que le plan
Juncker ne permettra pas
des temps très très longs
nécessitera quand même à retour sur
investissement pour l'investissement
privé qui mettra de l'argent à
l'intérieur de ces projets donc on
pourra effectivement avoir des projets
dans le plan Juncker y compris des
projets de l'espace mais pour tout ce
qui est très long très coûteux et pour
lesquels le retour sur investissement
est faible ou inexistant non il faudra
garder les projets les budgets de
recherche fondamentaux tels qu'ils
existent alors retournons un peu dans
les étoiles en parlant d'Ariane du futur
lanceur en fait
est-ce que ce type de programme permet à
l'Europe de conserver une autonomie
stratégie est-ce que la conquête
spatiale en un mot est toujours un
objectif politique
parce que je rêve en tout cas c'est sûr
ou un objectif politique je pense que
oui aujourd'hui ça permet quand même de
donner à l'Europe l'accès à l'espace
donc si vous n'avez pas l'accès à
l'espace tu vois c'est les technologies
des lanceurs vous perdez votre
souveraineté est-ce que vous n'avez pas
peur que l'Europe se sorte de la course
pour le dire autrement représente quand
même parce que leader des lanceurs dans
le monde qui sont on n'a pas tellement
le choix et je me suis rien raison de le
dire la question de la souveraineté
européenne qui est tout à fait
indispensable sur la technologie de
l'espace et notamment les satellites etc
elle existe sur plein de sujets aussi
elle existe sur la ligne
énergétique l'autonomie alimentaire ce
sont là des vraies questions européennes
qu'il faut que l'on pose aux citoyens en
toute transparence et dans le débat
public parce que effectivement sinon
demain nous serons obligés d'acheter en
Chine aux États-Unis soit votre
alimentation soit nos surveillances
spatiales nos satellites pour la
communication etc donc la question de la
souveraineté et donc la question de
l'investissement européen et des budgets
européens est une question fondamentale
essentielle
par exemple que vous n'ayez pas de
lancer et en ce moment-là vous allez
demander aux Russes ou aux Américains ou
chinois
pour l'instant nous sommes dans la
course tout à fait pour les lanceurs
programme Ariane 6 qui est un programme
d'évolution du 5 était un programme et
en sur lourd nous permet d'assurer je
pense 20 prochaines années et celui-là
il est financé ce programme
s'apercevoir qu'il y avait un petit
Delta qui manquait mais ce programme il
est lancé et financé
Isabelle Thomas que ce programme est
financé mais je confirme que ce
programme est lancé mais je confirme
surtout qu'il faut être très vigilant
pour qu'il n'y ait pas de coupe
budgétaire et que finalement le plan
d'investissement pour la croissance et
l'emploi ne soit pas paradoxalement un
plan qui nous ampute de nos projets
d'avenir qui sont vitaux pour l'Union
européenne alors une dernière question
Rosetta c'est un exemple
réussi on l'a dit de coopération de long
terme entre entre les plusieurs pays
européens ça a été réalisé rappelons-le
dans le cadre de l'Agence
spatiale européenne donc une coopération
intergouvernementale est-ce que ça
pourrait servir cette coopération
réussie est-ce qu'elle pourrait être
appliquée dans dans d'autres domaines
plus pratiques
c'est la métaphore de l'Europe c'est à
dire c'est un truc formidable personne
l'a fait avant nous mais ça s'est posé
un endroit où il y a pas de soleil et on
attend qu'il y a un peu plus de soleil
pour relancer les batteries parce que la
mission n'est pas finie
européen un peu de soleil sur nos
batteries ça nous ferait du bien plutôt
que au contraire de l'europhobie et un
mot pour terminer
pour terminer et bien moi je pense que
effectivement
l'Europe a besoin d'être relancé
il faut pour cela que nous sessions
cette période qui a été une période de
glaciation budgétaire de restrictions
budgétaire qui nous a un peu paralysé et
il faut que nous relancions l'économie
et pour ça sortir de l'austérité
budgétaire européenne et bien merci
d'avoir participé à ce débat à ce retour
sur ce saut de filae un petit saut de
robot mais un saut de géant pour
l'Europe c'est la fin de cette émission
on se retrouve la semaine prochaine même
lieu même heure bye bye